je me suis un peu foutu dans la merde
maman la dernière fois que tu m'as dit
ça ça m'a coûté mon job
Eddie a dit qu'il a besoin de moi pour
tenir le central pendant quelques heures
apparemment vous avez une grosse urgence
je dirais plutôt un cambriolage
qu'est-ce qui manque quatre pistolets TR
ces et un Bereta APX chaque chose on
s'entend il faut récupérer nos armes je
risque pas de gagner les élections si
j'arrive pas à mettre de l'ordre dans ma
propre
maison tenez bon on arrive dans 5
minutes ici là temple au bureau du
shérif à Jericho Ridge on nous tire
dessus envoyez-nous des
renforts mets-toi S arrête deer laiss
sortir d'ici
mets-toi au
sol exactement ce que je te dis il y a
des mecs dehors et ils sont
armés ils arrivent s de là et je tu pas
le gamin les renfor sont il faut qu'on
tienne jusqu'à ce qu'il arriv ok maman
s'il te plaît on arrête avec les
mensonges oh tu es rien d'autre qu'une
de plus que ras ce qu'elle
mérite j'ai fou quand fils de
maintenant tu avances et tu prends
le contrôle de tout
ça